ici gérald fillion comment expliquer la
chute des cours du pétrole
c'est un peu plus que le concept d'offre
et de demande qui a entraîné la chute
des prix du pétrole depuis juin 2014
la dégringolade a été spectaculaire une
baisse de plus de 50%
les prix à new york et à londres qui se
situer entre 100 et 115 dollars sont
tombées sous la barre des 50 dollars
c'est une première depuis la crise
financière et la grande récession de
2008 2009
que s'est il donc passé premièrement les
états unis la production de pétrole de
schiste a bondi avec la technologie de
la fracturation
ce qui fait que la production totale
américaine a grimpé de 50% depuis 2006
deuxièmement la croissance de la chine
plus faible qu'attendu nous ne sommes
plus dans l'ordre de 9 à 10% de hausse
du pib par année la croissance de la
deuxième économie mondiale est tombée
sous la barre des 7% la croissance de la
zone euro demeurent faibles
la russie est en récession le japon
vient tout juste d'en sortir et
l'allemagne s'en est approché la demande
mondiale en pétrole crois donc moins
rapidement que l'offre troisièmement
l'arabie saoudite
c'est le plus grand producteur des pays
de l'opep l'organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole l'arabie
saoudite refuse catégoriquement de
réduire sa production pour stopper la
baisse des cours du pétrole
le pays qui peut produire du pétrole à
faible coût souhaite conserver ses parts
de marché en asie et il fait la vie dure
à ses ennemis
l'iran et la russie cette ligne dure
maintien des prix à de faibles niveaux
dans une entrevue à rdi économie
l'analyste géopolitique pierre fournier
nous expliquer que l'arabie saoudite
n'avait pas pour objectif de faire plier
les américains afin qu'ils réduisent
leur production
selon lui l'économie américaine peut
très bien vivre avec une réduction de
production de pétrole
son économie est suffisamment diversifié
la stratégie saoudienne vise davantage
les autres producteurs de lax iran
russie venezuela
le canada est victime de ce
chassé-croisé pétroliers si les états
unis peuvent ralentir leur production de
pétrole sans en subir de conséquences
économiques graves
l'économie canadienne et les finances
publiques du gouvernement fédéral sont
malmenés c'est environ 30% des
investissements des entreprises au
canada qui sont faits dans le gaz et
dans le pétrole
et selon l'association canadienne des
producteurs pétroliers
les investissements vont chuter de 12
milliards de dollars cette année il y
aura environ 40 % moins de forage et ses
près de 25000 emplois qui sont à risque
à ottawa le gouvernement fédéral devra
se priver de plus de 5 milliards de
dollars en revenus
selon le directeur parlementaire du
budget ce qui met à risque le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
et parce que l'économie tout entière
ralenti la banque du canada a décidé de
réduire son taux directeur en janvier à
la surprise générale